Well, good morning church family.
It is, uh, the month we're celebrating our 60th
anniversary as a church.
And so all month you're gonna get to see things like
that history and, uh,
insights from people along the way who've been a part
of this for a really long time.
All culminating at the end of the month,
we're gonna celebrate in a big way that last Sunday
and even that Saturday night before.
Uh, before we get into God's word today, I want us
to just look back for a second, not 60 years ago,
but just to a week ago.
Uh, last week was such a big weekend with Good Friday
and with Easter Sunday, and even Wednesday night
before that with Marketplace.
And there was so much that was just stunning about
those few days, right?
I mean, when we sit back and look and examine
and reflect, we get
to see such incredible things that God did.
Uh, for example, on Friday, I talked to roughly half
of the people that came through.
I was on this side as people were entering.
And, uh, of the 3000 people that came through that day,
I estimated about 40% of them were first timers
going through Good Friday.
That's a big deal because of what it means
and how that impacts the lives.
And then last Sunday, uh, if you were here,
especially at the nine 30,
there were people sitting along the walls and it was crazy.
But, uh, our Easter attendance this year, as opposed
to last year was about 17% increase year over year.
And so that's just amazing what God's doing.
And I say that not to in, in any way brag about what God
or about what we've done.
It's because this is what God has done in the sense
that the people were showing up not for a, a circus
or a performance or anything.
It was for the gospel, right?
Like Good Friday, walking through it is straight
Christ and I crucified.
And then you see, Sunday, what we talked about,
it was a normal Sunday for us, but it was Christ
and I crucified again.
And so that's what's beautiful to me about that.
So what we wanted to do is just say a big thank
you to everyone involved.
If you served Wednesday night with the marketplace,
or Friday or Sunday in any way, setting up, tearing down,
greeting, smiling at kids, praying, whatever it was
over the last week, last week, I want you
to stand up right now and we can honor you for the effort
because it is so much work of what happened last week.
So please stand if you have like there was more than two
right there.
Please stand. Thank you.
Yes, if you did, it takes so many people
to do all of those things and to make it work.
So praise God for that. But it was a sacrifice of praise.
I know you did it with that spirit.
Uh, just as another side note, I wanna remind you
that every Sunday is Easter Sunday in a sense, right?
Resurrection day. So
what I felt coming in last Sunday was this anticipation kind
of an expectation that God's gonna work and do something.
Let's come every week with that, right?
Because it's still the same truth
that we're preaching every week.
We're talking about the same songs we're singing every week
about the life, death, and resurrection of Christ.
That's what I would hope we can come into with that way,
because God is faithful to that.
He is faithful, is that not just a beautiful phrase and,
and that word faithful, it means that he is dependable,
he's trustworthy, he's someone we can put our confidence in
because that's who he is.
That's what he is. Like. He can't be anything but faithful.
And we're gonna celebrate that over the next month of
what he's done over the last 60 years,
been faithful to this church.
But what I hope to see throughout this series in the book
of one Corinthians, is that he continues
to be faithful every day.
It's not just we look back
and see what he's done, it's he's still to you
and to me, faithful.
And we'll see that as we go.
So take your copy of God's word, turn with me to the book
of one Corinthians, the first letter
to the Corinthians in the New Testament.
You can find it there. First Corinthians, we're not going
through the whole book in seven weeks.
Don't worry about that. But what we're going to do is, what,
what I did is I, I looked through the book using software
and found every time the word faithful
or faith shows up in this letter.
It's probably more than just seven, but,
but these seven are the sections
that we're gonna study in this series, looking at
God's faithfulness to us
or how his faithfulness to us then
fuels our faithfulness to him.
How we can put our faith in him. We can be faithful to him.
That's the dynamic of this relationship as we go.
And so today we're gonna start in one Corinthians chapter
two, big number two.
The first five verses is
what we're gonna see this start with today.
By the way, this is the first passage I ever preached
here six years ago.
Uh, if you remember, if you were here at the time,
this is a football, you remember that Vince Lombardi, right?
Uh, and then also that I'm just a table waiter serving you
don't remember me, remember the chef, right?
That was the whole, anyway, that was a long time ago.
So we're gonna read it
and then we're gonna get into it here.
One Corinthians two, one through five,
and I, when I came to you, brothers,
did not come proclaiming to you the testimony of God
with lofty speech or wisdom.
For I decided to know nothing among you except Jesus Christ
and Him crucify.
I was with you in weakness and in fear.
And in much trembling my speech
and my message were not implausible words of wisdom,
but in demonstration of the spirit
and of power, so
that your faith might not rest in the wisdom of men,
but in the power of God.
Lord, that's what we want.
We want demonstration
of the power of the Spirit of God,
lives transformed families, restored
people walking in repentance, mission going.
We want the demonstration of the power of the Spirit.
So Lord, help us see it.
Change our hearts where we need it today
because you are faithful.
We can trust you, help help us trust you more
God, in Jesus' name.
Amen. So what do we need
to remember today from this passage?
Well, it's actually a quote from a different
part of a different letter.
Second Corinthians, the first letter here,
there's another letter that we call Second Corinthians.
It's actually a quote from there where Paul wrote this,
for when I am weak,
then I'm strong boiling it down.
If that's the only thing you remember today, when I am weak,
then I am strong.
That's quite the paradox, isn't it?
Like how can those two things both be true at the same time?
Plus, that verse is so counterintuitive to the ways
of our world and even to our own flesh
that both say, man, I gotta be strong.
I gotta have it all together. I gotta be impressive.
I need to put this best foot forward.
And then even our flesh inside of ourselves, we say, man,
I can't show weakness.
Like even inside, I can't show anything weakness.
And so what it does is it prompts me to look in the mirror
and declare I'm good enough, I'm smart enough,
and dog on it, people like me, right?
Like that's what we say. We have to tell ourselves
that we gotta, we gotta buckle down
and strengthen up and say, here we are.
I've got this handled.
That's why we need to first understand who we truly are,
because that's the way of the world,
that's the way of our flesh.
We've got to understand who we truly are.
That's the first piece of this,
especially in relation to who God is.
We better understand who we are.
I want just to stop for a second.
I want you to think about how you view yourself.
Like when you think about yourself, what's the first thing
that comes to mind?
What do you think about yourself?
Is it positive or is it overly critical?
Kind of just analyzing that, thinking about
where you stand out here is the reality.
Some of that comes from the way you were talked about
by your parents or your siblings when you were growing up.
We carry this baggage.
We have this sense that, that what we were kind of portrayed
to be by people that loved us or supposedly loved us.
At least we carry that in.
And so some of us walk with very negative views
of ourselves simply because of the way we grew up.
Or somebody might feel like I'm, I'm not worth anything,
because that's really what you were told.
Now, lemme just take a side note here for a second.
That's a lie straight from the pit of hell. Okay?
First of all, think about it. You're an image bearer of God.
That's big. And if you're a believer,
God died for you.
That's value, isn't it?
Like we are only seeing something
as valuable when something's, when someone's willing
to pay a certain amount for it, he gave his life
for you believer.
That's value. So don't believe the lie
that your parents told you
or that society told you your valuable.
So some of us might have this picture in ourselves
that we think we're worth nothing
or we're we're this lowest of the low.
But, but the flip side is also true.
And this may be even more true.
I'm not sure of the statistics exactly,
but some of us actually have a very inflated view
of ourselves that we think we're pretty awesome
and we want you to know about it.
We're kinda like this male peacock, strutting
around preening and saying, look at me.
Look how awesome I am. Look at how beautiful this is.
In fact, I, uh, I once saw this parody TV commercial,
uh, this was a, at a sermon illustration thing,
but it was for a CD called Me Worship.
And it included hits like how great
I am seeing with me.
How great, like that's on there or there is none like me.
No one else can do everything like I do, right?
That's, and those are the hits
that we would say on this me worship idea.
Here's the problem with that.
There's a lot of problems with that. But here's the problem.
Romans 12, three commands us.
Do not think of yourself more
highly than you ought to think.
I love how Philip translated that verse.
Do not cherish exaggerated ideas of yourself
or your importance.
Man, we sure do that, don't we?
But that's exactly what Paul's saying here.
It's why he came to Corinth
and the way that he came to this city,
because listen, if anyone had the ability to think highly
of themselves, it was Paul.
I mean, in the Jewish world,
this guy's letter jacket was packed, right?
You know what I mean by that, right? It was full.
He was, he was the top of the top, right.
Acts 22, verse three says, he was educated at the feet
of a prominent Jewish teacher in Jerusalem, strictly
zealous for God.
Even this, he says in Philippians chapter three,
he describes his, his history circumcised on the eighth day.
That was exactly when you should of the people of Israel,
of the tribe of Benjamin, even a Hebrew of Hebrews as
to the law of Pharisee, meaning the top of the top as
to zeal, a persecutor of the church.
Nobody else did that as to righteousness under the law,
blameless like this guy was the valedictorian.
He was Allstate, if you want to go that way, right?
He was the top even more than that.
This guy had the already ascended.
Jesus, meet him on the road, change his heart
and turn him into the greatest missionary,
the world's ever known Yet.
Look at how Paul viewed
himself in verse one.
What did he say? I didn't use lofty speech
or wisdom, meaning this like
flowery way of arguing.
And those, by the way, were traits
that were valued in Corinth because they loved debating.
They were looking for new ideas
and people who were the best rhetorical devices, all of
that's what they wanted.
And he says, no, no, no, I'm not gonna use that.
In fact, he saw himself in weakness, fear,
and much trembling.
Now, what we know about Paul, he probably had some kind
of debilitating illness or injury.
This is the, uh, thorn in the flesh
in second Corinthians 12.
We're not sure what it was, but it could have been a
physical thing, so that most likely factored in here.
We also know he was pretty unimpressive physically.
He wasn't a great speaker
that's said elsewhere in second Corinthians.
But then he also,
it probably also dealt with his emotional condition
as he came to Corinth the first time.
See, he had just come through on his missionary journey,
come through Thessalonica, come through Berea, and,
and what he had experienced, there was hostility
after hostility after hostility.
And it didn't go well.
He wasn't experiencing a great ministry fruit.
He was just getting beat up literally at times.
And so he might've walked into Corinth feeling like things
weren't working very well,
or maybe this, this thing's,
this ministry thing isn't really working out.
Maybe I need to do something else
where he might be tempted to think
that this really isn't worth it if I have to go
through all this and I don't even get
to see much of anything.
Have you ever been there before?
Have you ever been where you're not seeing any fruit
or much fruit at least?
And it just seems like, man, I'm getting harder
to share the gospel, to do ministry, to go serve.
It just feels like I can't do it anymore. I'm dry.
It's I'm sad.
So you just want to give up and you're weak
and you're fearful of doing it again
because you're gonna get hurt again.
Or you, that was Paul here, right?
Was with you in weakness, fear, trembling.
But really when you think about it, that was Paul. Yes.
But really that's all of us all the time.
See, truly at our core, in ourselves, we are weak.
Like we're trying to think, okay, who are we really?
We, we gotta remember
who we are, especially in relation to God.
But, but who are we first?
We have to remember, we are weak people.
This is what Psalm 73 reminds us that our flesh
and our hearts may fail.
Isaiah verse 30 of chapter 40, it says,
even youths shall faint and be weary
and young men shall fall exhausted.
Psalm 1 0 3 looks back to God creating humans,
and it reminds us the word dust.
Not impressive. We're dust.
See, as much as we want to think of ourselves as strong
and able and,
and yes, even comparatively to other people,
we might be in some ways,
but compared to God, we are
infinitely weak.
We bring nothing to the table. So we're weak.
But not only that, we're limited like we are weak
and we are limited
because remember, none of us can actually save anyone else.
We can't save anyone.
In fact, we can't even change anyone's mind.
Now, absolutely, we can and should bring reasoned arguments.
We should explain clearly like Paul
did in Athens and elsewhere.
He was good at that.
But if God doesn't work, it doesn't work.
If he doesn't do something to change a heart
or a mind, it isn't gonna happen.
No matter how good we are at arguing or explaining.
Plus, when you think about it, if we, if we begin
to trust in those reasoned arguments instead
of trusting in the simple truths
of the gospel, that's a problem.
That's what Paul was trying to get to.
He knew the Corinthians were, were prone towards camps.
Like they were saying, I'm, I follow this guy.
Here's my philosophy over here.
This guy's really good at explaining this.
So I follow him, or I follow this one.
He's good at, at tying around speakers or debaters.
And they, they knew that was true there in Corinth.
And so he said, no, no, no. I know my limitations.
I know this will not work. It can't be based on me.
It can't be based on my ability to argue.
Well, because I know somebody's gonna come later
who's better at it than I am.
And that can't be the case that you base your faith on that
it's got to be based on,
because that's where the true power lies.
Again, we've gotta view ourselves accurately
because that keeps us first from getting prideful.
This is what I can do.
But then it keeps us from trusting in man when we should
trust in God alone.
Remembering who we are keeps us there.
But there's also this other point.
You remember our main point quoting from two Corinthians 12.
It says that when we are weak, then we are strong, right?
So that's the main idea. How does that even work?
How does, how does weakness mean?
Strength Because the weak vessel is the vessel
that God actually uses.
And look back up. You're in one Corinthians chapter two,
right before that, the end of chapter one, verse 27.
He, he's talking about the gospel,
but he's also talking about the messenger of the gospel.
Verse 27 says, God chose what is foolish in the world
to shame the wise.
God chose what is weak in the world to shame the strong.
What Paul's doing here is he's describing the ideal vehicle
that God uses for the ministry,
saying this is the way the gospel works compared to the way
of the world, but it's also the way I work
through these vessels.
It's the same thing. He wrote this quote, I keep coming back
to second Corinthians 12.
He's writing there three times.
He asked God to take away this thorn.
He say, God, I want this gone. It hurts.
Whatever it is, take away the thorn in my flesh.
Here's how the back and forth goes with God. Check this out.
Second Corinthians 12, nine and 10.
But God said to me, my grace is sufficient
for you, for my power is made
perfect in weakness.
So Paul, therefore, I will boast all the more gladly
of my weaknesses, so that the power
of Christ may rest upon me for the sake of Christ.
Then I'm content with weaknesses, insults, hardships,
persecutions, calamities for when I'm weak,
then I am strong.
Right? It sounds like a paradox.
Yeah, that I'm, I,
I can't be weak and strong.
It doesn't work that way.
But he says, no, when I'm weak, then I'm strong. How?
Because when my weakness shows up,
that's when God's power shows up.
I mean, just think about it.
Who's more believable when they say,
I trust God with all that I am.
I trust God wholeheartedly. Who's more believable?
Someone who is a great speaker, has it all together.
They're wealthy, they're healthy. Everything is in order.
They're polished. It's all that way.
Or someone who is broken
and stutters, feeble.
There's, there's some sickness.
There's, there's a desperation.
Who's more believable? Say, I trust God.
One of those is tempted to trust in themselves.
To trust in what they have
or that they're a self-made man
or a self-made woman,
that they can sustain it all
and they're tempted to believe
that they don't really need God because I have all this.
Whereas one is in a spot of life
where they know they need him,
that they can't survive without him,
that they know he's worth it.
Even in the struggle who's more believable.
That's why God chooses the weak vessel
rather than the strong vessel.
Just this week, I stood with a man next to his wife.
They've been married over 40 years.
She's laying in a hospital bed as she neared the end
of her life, stricken with cancer the last few years,
and the framed pictures on the table next to her
revealed how much her earthly tint had been wasting away
over the last few years.
In fact, I got a text literally
before I walked up here that she died this morning.
Yet through tears on Wednesday, as he watches his wife die,
her husband shared how much this experience
had grown, both his faith and her faith
and how he watched her trust God
through it all
and suffer strongly through it all.
See our flesh in that moment, our, our world in
that moment looks at that and says, that's weakness.
What she's going through, she's dying.
That's why we push death away.
We don't want to deal with it because it's weakness.
Yet, when someone truly trusts the Lord in the middle
of that, they're actually strong
no matter what they're facing.
Again, not because we're strong in ourselves, but
because we remember who we truly are,
because we remember who God truly is, right?
That's the whole comparison thing we're talking about here.
This is remembering who we are,
but we've gotta also remember who God is in this process.
I mean, we're gonna go back through this passage in one
Corinthians two, so we've seen kind of who we are,
who Paul viewed himself to be, who we need to see ourselves
to be weak, limited.
But let's read the same passage with the perspective on
who God is this time.
Look at this again. One Corinthians two, one through five,
I, when I came to you, brothers, did not come proclaiming
to you the testimony of God with lofty speech or wisdom.
For I decided to know nothing among you except Jesus Christ
and Him crucify, and I was weak with you in weakness
and fear and much trembling my speech,
my message were not implausible, words of wisdom,
but in demonstration of the spirit of God
and of power, so
that your faith might not rest in the wisdom of men,
but in the power of God.
Notice how he saw God. What was his perspective on God?
He said, first, man, God is powerful.
God is powerful.
We're weak, but God is
powerful Twice in just two verses,
that word shows up, right?
Verse four and verse five, the power of God,
that God is powerful
and that he gives power to us as we live.
I know I keep going back to it,
but listen to second Corinthians 12, nine.
Again, God said to Paul,
my grace is sufficient for you,
for my power is made perfect in weakness.
It's completed. It's shown to be what it is.
In your weakness, Paul, in your weakness, believer
God's power is completed, shown up
through our weakness,
his powers revealed through weak vessels like you and me.
This is what Isaiah said. Same kind of context.
Isaiah 40 verses 28 through 31. Have you not known?
Have you not heard the Lord?
Yahweh is the everlasting God,
the creator of the ends of the earth.
He does not faint or grow weary.
His understanding is unsearchable.
He gives power to the faint and to him who has no might.
He increases strength.
Even youth us shall faint and be weary.
Young men shall fall exhausted,
but they who wait for the Lord shall renew their strength.
They shall mount up with wings like eagles.
They shall run and not be weary.
They shall walk and not faint. That's not you strong.
That's God's power flowing through you strong.
Remember who we are. We're weak, we're limited,
but remember who God is, right?
He's strong, he's powerful. We are weak in and of ourselves.
But listen, that is completely fine
because the more we acknowledge that,
the more God's power is clearly seen through us.
God's gonna do his work however he wants to,
however he chooses to.
But the most glory he receives is when he uses weak, feeble,
limited people like you and me.
I mean, he could Red Sea split this thing
and he could show off and do big things by himself.
Absolutely. But the more glory he gets is through us,
that he uses us as weak as we are.
But why does he do that?
One Corinthians one says, so
that no human being might boast in the presence of God.
Why does he choose to use limited, foolish people like us so
that we wouldn't boast, that we have nothing
to stand on ourselves?
'cause when we remember who we are truly in flight of
who God is truly,
that should make us the most humble
people in the face of the earth.
Here's what we do instead,
I know I do this, you do this.
We, we might even do it really quietly.
We don't do it publicly,
but we start a comparison game
between us and other people, don't we?
Body type wealth status,
theological knowledge, intelligence,
and we look around at people
and we say, I'm better than they are at that,
and we start to feel pretty good about ourselves.
Problem though. Yeah.
When we get out of the way, the
more we would acknowledge that we're not trying
to compare it to anybody else but God,
which means we then acknowledge our dependence on the Lord
in that, the more then he shows up
through our lives, we start comparing.
We start to play this game in the world,
and we start to see what we get from that.
The results we get from that, that anything we try
to do on our own will fail
or will not produce the fruit God
wants to produce through our lives.
We start to do it on our own. We start to compare.
We start to try to to buck up and try harder,
and we make it happen ourselves.
What we get the results of that,
by the way, this is including
where we think we can argue someone into salvation,
or we come up with slick marketing ways to try
to manipulate emotions, to get people
to come forward on a Sunday and say some prayer,
and they feel no conviction, but they've done something
because they think they should.
This is, this is our own strength. But what did Paul say?
I didn't use the means the world uses.
I simply resolved to proclaim to you the gospel of Christ
and him crucified.
That's all he did. He comes
to Corinth, he says, I'm weak.
Don't put your trust in me. Don't hope in me.
Don't think I'm some reasoned
philosophical argument that you can stand on.
That's not my job, my job, what he says in Romans
one 16, he says, my job simply,
I'm not ashamed of the gospel, for it is the power of God
for salvation to everyone who believes, both
to the Jew and also to the Greek.
He says, the gospel, the good news
of Christ is the power of God.
And so hear me today, place your faith not in me,
not in a system, not in a reasoned argument.
Place your faith in the power of God because he is powerful,
but also because he's unlimited.
You're weak, you're limited. I'm weak, I'm limited.
God is powerful, and God is unlimited.
The means of this world, you
and I, we are limited,
but God is unlimited.
And think about that again in the context of our passage,
one Corinthians two, look at verse five again.
It says, so that your faith might not rest in the wisdom
of men, the ways of the world, the systems that we have.
So your faith might not rest in that,
but in the power of God.
So he says, faith here, what kind
of faith is he talking about?
He's clearly talking about saving faith, right?
He's talking about our eternity.
No human wisdom can do that.
No reason argument can give us salvation eternally.
We can't get there, but only the power of God
through the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus in our place.
That's the key that unlocks everything else.
And so he says Christ and him crucified.
That's what I am proclaiming.
But let's just stop for a second.
Let's, let's reflect on that for a moment
and peel back another layer of this idea
that he's talking about here.
Your faith resting in the power of God.
So think about this. If God is faithful
to take care of your eternal life,
If, if he is that unlimited,
that our eternity is completely taken care
of by God, so we don't have to fear death, we don't have
to fear anything frightening that can happen to us.
Now, we don't have to fear in that
'cause God's unlimited, he's taking care of our eternity.
If God is faithful to take care of our eternal life,
then don't you think he can take care of our daily life too?
Like why would we limit God to only after we die?
Which you often hear that right?
Salvation, I get to go to heaven, great,
but why would we live as if he's in charge of eternity,
but we get to be in charge today
that he's got that taken care of.
But it only happens when I die or when he comes back. Why?
Why would we? It doesn't make any sense, right?
But we do it every day.
What Paul's talking about
of resting in man's wisdom does not just have to do
with eternity and reasoned arguments about his salvation
and, and who's the savior.
It's not just about that.
It's about even our daily lives
that we're still prone to daily trust
in the ways of the world, in man's wisdom,
in our own strength.
Okay? So how do we know? Like
how do we know when we're doing that?
Because we don't want to, I, I think we all would agree,
like we don't wanna trust in our own selves
and our own strength and man's wisdom.
We don't want any of that. How do we know we are?
Listen, when I don't pray, I'm trusting myself.
When, when I rarely confess
sin in a genuine way, then I,
I think I don't really need to confess sin
if I rarely live below my means,
so I can give sacrificially.
I never face a moment where I have to actually trust God
to come through for me, and we could
go on and on, right?
But when we think we are powerful,
when we think we are unlimited,
we forget who we actually
are and what happens.
We get weak results. Our lives are limited
by our own feeble, feudal capacity,
and we get what we have right now.
Probably that's why at church,
when we look at our lives, when we look at our families,
we look at our church, we've got to remember who we are,
especially in light of who he is.
Two Corinthians four says that we have this treasure
of the gospel in jars of clay.
And what he means by that is the gospel is the the treasure.
We're just a bunch of clay pots.
We have this treasure in jars of clay to show
that the surpassing power belongs to God and not to us.
It's not about the container. It's not about you and me.
It's about the treasure who God has shown it to be.
It's the gospel. That's why when we
are weak, he is powerful.
When we are limited,
he is unlimited.
That's why we've got to get to the place where we say,
when we are weak, not, not if we're weak, when we are weak,
when we acknowledge our weakness
before the Lord, that's when we're strong,
because that is when the power
of God begins to flow through us.
So let's be weak, church.
Let's be weak together.